hey I'm on this shoot baby opinion dad
Jesse in the back bruh I wanna thank
your mother for like that shotgun
back
maximov fxk calm 4-wire Deadpool's
wisecracking
dark mutant hero wade wilson is directed
by Tim Miller himself a founder of blur
and animation and effects how so it
comes as no real surprise that this film
delivers some loud and in-your-face
visual effects now for us one of the
most interesting characters is Colossus
who was primarily done by Digital Domain
it's often been said that VFX is a
collaborative effort and this is really
borne out by this metallic x-men
character to capture the motion of the
character there was a motion capture
studio session done but there was also a
separate six-foot 9-inch performer
filmed on location in a classic gray
tracking suit although he still wasn't
tall enough and had to wear either
platform shoes or an extra headpiece for
height but closest face was modeled on a
third performer with a much more
chiseled jawline a fourth performer
actually then redid all of the dialogue
lines but even then the actual facial
animation of those lines was delivered
by somebody else
Digital domains Greg LaSalle who was
filmed using their proprietary movi rig
the rig works using ultraviolet light to
pick up special spattered paint which
produce incredibly accurate facial
models though of course those are
incredibly accurate facial models of
Greg who doesn't look anything like
Colossus so Digital Domain has to then
retarget this performance to the
metallic facial model for this Digital
Domain uses their new direct drive
system which as the name implies allows
Greg's performance to drive the CG face
while still maintaining high-frequency
subtle movements finally the animators
get to tweak and refine this performance
and adjust it for the kind of
deliberately solid metallic look this is
particularly important for Colossus as
he has metal ridges and lines which are
intended to be even and perfectly
straight which is impossible to maintain
an animated action sequence like
Deadpool so Digital Domain invented
something new again called live
texturing which allowed them to adjust
the metal work just right no matter how
he moved in any particular sequence well
for more behind the scenes action please
subscribe i mike seymour for Wired
have you seen this man wait did I leave
the stove on